[Music]
have you ever seen a glitch like mistake
in a show sometimes it's hard to believe
that one of your favorite TV series
could have actually made several small
mistakes see what Liv and Maddie
mistakes shocked you most especially
number one about which twin is older if
this is your first time visiting the
things don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
here are 10 mistakes and Liv and Maddie
you might have missed Maddie can sing
aside from their appearance Liv and
Maddie aren't very different characters
though their eyesight and voice are some
of the most noticeable ways in which
they differ another aspect of their
unique talents
for example while Liv is a talented
singer Maddie can barely screech out a
note this is made very clear to the
audience in season 1 during the
switcheroonie episode to refresh your
memory Liv and natty decide to pretend
to be one another for a day they decide
to do this so that Liv can land a role
as Tristan that she believes would be
the next best step for her acting and
singing career unfortunately she knows
very little about space werewolves while
Maddie is a mega fan the girls take
advantage of being identical twins and
Maddie agrees to stand in for live
during the singing loud DVD signing
after stumbling on stage as a result of
her poor eyesight
Maddie thanks everyone for their
attendance and song or at least it was
meant to be in song that comes out as a
terrible screech that definitely throws
off her fans so this establishes that
Maddie can't carry a tune she
miraculously chimes in with leg when she
performs count me in in the song or
Rooney episode tarantulas in team Rooney
the episode begins when Parker takes
home his class pets a group of six
tarantulas however a problem quickly
arises when Parker introduces Joey to
only one tarantula
Parker states that he lost the other
five they find one crawling across the
table and trap it under a bowl the boys
understandably want to try to find the
missing for tarantulas without their
mother finding out Parker and Joey spend
the rest of the episode trying to track
on the missing prospects they managed to
find one crawling across a member of the
basketball team
while she's fast asleep at the team
sleepover the rest remain unseen and
apparently multiplied during their
disappearance when they finally do break
the news to Karen she takes it pretty
well she Commons said now that she knows
it almost feels like spiders are
crawling all over her spoiler alert
they are the weird thing is that there
are at least four and maybe even a fifth
spider clinging to her sweater people
must need some math tutoring because
last time we counted three tarantulas
were back in Parkers captivity so there
should only be three loose not four and
certainly not five return of the
artichoke ornaments Raider Rooney takes
place on peeps birthday as such she
declares that for his birthday he wants
negative five things
this means that he gets to get rid of
five things in the house that Karen
bought but he considers to be clutter he
relishes the moment he gets to do away
with the artichoke candle holder
Karen protests but ends up giving in
nostalgically remembering how she bought
it for Parker after he tried artichokes
for the first time Karen takes the loss
but we can tell that it pains her to
part with an ornament that has emotional
significance for her it is strange that
this coin is made in the episode yet the
artichoke candle holder makes a comeback
several times for example in Grandma
Rooney while Maggie is desperately
trying to attain her grandmother's
approval Parker comes downstairs dressed
as a baby parker is trying to reclaim
his role as the adorable baby in order
to receive his usual twenty dollar gifts
from his Nana as he walks down the
stairs we can clearly see that the
artichoke candle holder is back on a
side table somehow it has made its way
into the house and no one addresses its
return fake dreams and imagined dresses
in cow Bella Rooney we spotted not one
but two mistakes let's start with a side
issue that caught our eye
this mistake occurs in the school
hallways when Liv is explaining to her
voltage co-star Josh about cowbell week
Liv excitedly introduces him to the
rules involved in cowbell week at
Ridgewood High as she's finishing her
explanation and Josh is already
beginning to strategize his cowbell
moves
willow comes around the corner and stops
mackynzie in her tracks she provides a
perfect
to the trickery involved in cow Belling
someone as she shouts out to Mackenzie
complimenting her dress she claims her
dress matches the cowbell she continues
to hang around Mackenzie's neck the
problem Mackenzie is very clearly
wearing a top and skirt and not a dress
more related to the episode at the end
of the episode while maddie is enjoying
her victory as the three-time champion
of cowbell week she points to one of the
girls a fellow student and clothes that
she Cal bailed her in her sleep this is
not true however as that same girl is
the first victim to Maddie's cowbell in
talent what is strange mistake to make
fortunately for Maddie
it doesn't undermined her rule as
milkmaids X's can't be friends by the
fourth season of Liv and Maddie it's
only natural that some of the
relationships between the characters get
a little blurry and it's much easier to
lose track of the characters history
however it seems very unlikely that
anyone let alone the show's producers
would forget about the relationship
between Maddie and diggie
according to exer Rooney some of the
details regarding how Maddie and diggie
handled their breakup were forgotten
this episode begins with Joey and Josh
rehearsing for their action movie while
Maddie is at practice when she comes
home early it's Joey
who's the most awkward about the former
couple coming face to face maddie is
relatively cool about it and josh goes
as far as inviting maddie to join him
and joey for lunch the next time we see
them they are enjoying their meal that
involves a chip pyramid and Maddie says
she's surprisingly glad she came for
lunch
who says exes can't be friends Maddie
should not be so surprised as this has
already happened with diggie further
what would give Joey any reason to feel
that it would be weird when it's worked
out in the past lives hair in season 1 &
2 of Liv and Maddie live sports the same
hairstyle her wavy middling hair is cut
in layers that frame her face in
contrast Maddie keeps her hair pulled
back in a low ponytail the first episode
of season 3 is called continuum Rooney
the title is self-explanatory as season
two's last episode Rayder Rooney ends in
a cliffhanger this is a usual and common
strategy to keep viewers eagerly
awaiting the next season of a series in
this case however the follow-up episode
demonstrated a slight
lakyn awareness live looks different as
she greets Maddie when she enters the
house in a side-by-side frame our
suspicions are confirmed as it becomes
clear that Liv's hair has changed just
enough to alter her look this episode
though was supposed to take place
immediately after the last episode of
the previous season how then we ask you
to live get a chance to revamp her hair
though it's a small detail that
audiences would happily overlook for the
return of the show
it's a noticeable continuity mistake
lives extra hair length is just enough
to throw the continuation of the
previous episode off and breaks the
fourth wall for viewers it reminds us
that the show has been fabricated for us
with a break between seasons diss
illusion acting and opposite yourself we
would imagine can get pretty complicated
and dove Cameron doesn't pretty great
job as both Liv and Maddie in order to
be able to pull off the illusion of
having both Maddie and live on screen
each character needs to remain on their
side of the screen if they fail to do
this then we see parts of them disappear
this is a mistake in the episode Callie
Christmas a Rooney the first incident in
this episode occurs early on when Maddie
laments having to spend Christmas in LA
instead of in Wisconsin in an attempt to
cheer her up Liv points out the festive
lighting of the Christmas palm tree it's
at this moment when she turns around to
touch Maddie's reaction that the corner
of her green purse disappears it's only
for a second but looks like a total
glitch if you catch it Dov was standing
slightly too close to her mark and it
resulted in a pretty trippy image you
can tell that limb is conscious of where
she's meant to stand as she looks down
and realizes her leg is over the line
after hugging Joey we see what you did
there keeping up appearances definitely
isn't as easy as it looks
facegab call move Aruna is an
unforgettable episode since as Liv says
it marks the birth of Mickey it's been a
long time coming and Liv speaks for all
of us as she comments on the symbolism
of diggie Wendy Liv his letterman jacket
meanwhile Maddie is stuck trying to
interpret the most mundane moments they
share down to every sup they exchanged
at the same time karen is obsessing over
other words as she learns that app is
not a PP Karen's familiarization with
her new iPhone offsets some of the
intensity of waiting anxiously to see if
Maddie and diggie will come clean about
how they feel about one another however
admits the excitement is a pretty
obvious mistake that we're sure you
would pick up on if you are watching the
episode closely Parker shows Karen how
to use the video chat app facegab
while Karen and Parker gives the off a
try in a video chat with Liv Parker
notices Liv Isis snow cone maker
Liv plays confused and ends the call the
mistake is that the call is ended by Liv
pressing the speaker as her finger goes
nowhere near the disconnect button maybe
Karen isn't the only one in need of a
tech lesson Maddie and Linds age in the
very first episode within the first two
minutes
the audience is introduced to our twin
protagonists Liv and Maddie we first
meet live as she's entering your house
and being reunited with her family after
having filmed four seasons of her TV
show sing it loud the first person she
embraces is her twin maddie whom she
accuses of stealing her face this is the
moment we learned that maddie is the
older twin as her comeback is I had it
first
however only eight episodes later in
Sweet sixteen aruna Caryn and Pete
reveal that Maddie and Liv were actually
born on two separate days although this
may be a potential solution for the
girls who can't agree on how to
celebrate their birthday it nonetheless
shocks them to find out that Liv was
born on the fifth at 11:56 p.m. while
Maddie was born on the 6th at 12:02 a.m.
Pete and Karen do a pretty good job of
justifying their decision of keeping
this secret for the rest of the episode
the mistake is as the entire episode
relies on the premise that Liv was
formed before Maddie a complete
contradiction to the information we were
given in the first episode when the
twins reunite
and that's all for the tech mistakes and
live in nutty you might have missed make
sure to LIKE this video and subscribe to
the things to catch more videos like
this thanks for watching
[Music]